the Joe Rogan experience some happy
little place where you know someone's
feeding you peeled grapes that isn't
what it is it's it's more like it's my
more like victory on the Honorable
battlefield or something like that you
have the the perception that people have
of ultimate success and ultimate
happiness is it seems motivated by what
they don't have rather than an
understanding of what success and
happiness really is their their idea is
that one day I'm gonna go and I'm gonna
be in my golden years and I'm just gonna
be able to sit around and do nothing and
tell everybody to [ __ ] off you won't be
happy yeah I talked to one of the people
that I was working with who had a like a
vision for retirement said well what's
your vision for retirement well I see
myself in the beach you know some
tropical country drinking margaritas and
I thought first that's what I plan
that's a travel poster it's like okay
let's let's walk through this all right
so you go down to this tropical country
and you go sit on the beach and you have
a margarita it's like okay well how many
margaritas like 10 do that for six
months you'll be dead yeah well you'll
be this like pathetic sunburned like fat
yeah I'm happy so how long can you have
a margarita on a beach like maybe you
can do that once every six months for
like 10 minutes something like that it's
not a vision it's true but when you are
working and slaving away you think about
that beach with your feet up yeah and
the waiter comes over would you like
another margarita mr. Peterson yes but
it's like this 16 year old fantasy of
paradise and it just doesn't work out so
yeah and and the thing the thing is is
that the thing that sustains people
through life really is the lifting of a
worthwhile burden it's something like
that
yeah that's partly because we're social
animals right it's like we're evolved to
be useful to the people around us
because they're much more likely to let
us live if we're like that yeah so and
and it's been very fun talking to
especially talking to young men about
this is like well and that's the other
thing too is I think the world the world
is full of darkness let's say and we
should say each of us have a little bit
of light and if we release that light if
we let it shine properly Christ it's too
clichéd to go on with in some sense but
the world is a lesser place if you do
not reveal from within yourself what you
have to reveal and the fact that the
world is a lesser place actually turns
out not to be trivial like if you want
everything you could be more people will
die
more people will suffer more evil will
be unconstrained more tyranny will reign
more chaos will remain chaotic and
dangerous all of that do you mean this
by this in the sense of like the old
proverb of the wings of a butterfly
fluttering become a hurricane it's it's
it's something similar to that but it
can even be more local it's like your
family is more messed up than it could
be if you were less messed up than you
are
right so if you just got your act
together like 10% more your family would
be 1% better right it's like well do it
and that would ripple off and demo
people today and it ripples fast yes
that's the other thing that's so cool is
that like people think well there's
seven billion of us and each of us is
just this separate dust mote like
floating in the cosmos and what the hell
difference does it make what you do
anyways it's like that is not how we're
connected it's like you're the center of
a network and you know well you know way
more people than this but let's say
typically you know without you're gonna
know a thousand people in your life well
enough to have an impact on them okay
and each of those thousand people is
going to know a thousand people so
you're one step from a million and two
steps from a billion and we are Network
technically that that's how human
interactions work and so when you do
something that you shouldn't do it's
worse than you think and when you do
something that you should do it's better
than you think and so you think well
this is why I've been telling people
clean up your room that's like well your
room is actually networked too
it's not that easy to clean up your room
to set it so you want your room to be
set up so that when you walk in there it
tells you to be better than you
generally are it's organized
it's got direction everything's in its
place you try to do that in a chaotic
household you know I've watched people
do this because I had students do these
sorts of things as assignments I'd say
look
pick a small morale goal clean up your
room and just write down what happens as
a consequence so maybe these are
students in a chaotic household the
whole place is a bloody mess no one's
taking any responsibility for anything
and so they decide they're gonna start
to clean up their room and then the
people in the household notice well the
first thing they do is get pissed off
it's like who do you think you are like
you think you're better than us yes like
why do you think this is worthwhile who
made who died and made you God all of
that so just by trying to organize this
little part of their life they
immediately run into the people whose
actions they're casting in a dim light
by trying to improve themselves to some
degree they might have to have like a
thorough war in their household to be
allowed to do something as simple as
keep the room orderly they find out very
rapidly that eh that's way more
difficult than it sounds and be that the
consequences of it are far more
far-reaching than people think so that's
quite fun
you know because maybe part of it is is
that like everything around you is full
of potential everything maybe more
potential than you could ever possibly
utilize and so maybe all you have is
this little rat hole of a room and some
rundown place in the world it's like fix
it up there's more there than you think
see what happens if you fix it up and
you'll fix yourself up simultaneously
because you have to get disciplined in
order to fix up the room then you have a
fixed up room and you'll be a more fixed
up person it's like you think that
nothing will happen as a consequence of
that it's like all hell will break loose
as a consequence of that worth try it is
worth trying and it's it's a concept
that seems alien to people but if you
think about it it makes sense well
people don't take what they have right
in front of them seriously enough it's
like the wasting time thing they don't
do the arithmetic you know and they'd
also don't understand they devalue what
they have right in front of them like
another another client I worked with it
was having a hard time putting his kid
to bed at night and so we did the
arithmetic it's like well I'm fighting
with my kid for 45 minutes a night
trying to get him to go to bed okay so
let's analyze that all right so what
does that mean well it means that both
of you end the day upset that's not so
good because why would you want that it
means that you're spending 45 minutes
fighting when you could spend 20 minutes
doing something positive like reading
you say means that you don't get to
spend that time with your wife so she's
not very happy with you plus you're
annoyed because you don't see her plus
you blame it on the kid because he's the
proximal cause it's like that's pretty
damn ugly and then and then let's do the
arithmetic it's like seven days a week
45 minutes a day let's call that five
hours 20 hours a week 240 hours in a
year it's 6 you're spending a month and
a half of work weeks fighting with your
four-year-old son I think you're gonna
like him you don't like anyone you spend
a month and a half a year fighting with
it's a bad idea fix it it's important
get him to bed make it peaceful you do
it like these things that repeat every
single day that's a motif in this book
to your life isn't margaritas on a beach
and in Jamaica that happens now and then
those are exceptions your life is how
your wife greets you at the door when
you come home every day because that's
like 10 minutes a day your life is how
you treat each other over the breakfast
table because that's an hour and a half
or an hour every single day you get
those mundane things right those things
you do every day you've concentrated on
them and you make them pristine it's
like you've got 80% of your life put
together these little things that are
right in front of us they're not little
that's the first thing they are not
little and they're hard to set right and
if you set them right it has a rippling
effect and and fast to way faster than
people think
[Applause]